[Music]
all right
china i mean harmony harmony how are you
i'm good so
harmony tell me what has been going on
in your life you've had a
crazy life for a 13 you're not 14 years
old right
yeah it's been a real story tell me
what's going on
so lately i have been back
in la but i've stopped everything that i
was doing
so you're you're back in la for what
reason because because last time we
did that interview with your mom you
ended up going back to kansas city with
her
yeah i'm back out here because
i'm going through a lot of stuff with
the system and stuff like that the legal
system so
i i'm not i'm back out here but i prefer
to be at home but you want to be home
with your family
yeah but what they're doing it's hard
for me
to do any
like to just you know get back out there
and just you know
i can't keep going back and forth so so
you
so you go back to your family but you
end up getting pulled back to los
angeles
because of uh because they don't want me
with my mom
and i it's no reason they should not
want me with my mom
so there was no abuse in your childhood
there was no your dad your dad was
a good father and your mom
was she was busy working a lot when she
was younger but now she's
at home with your sister i'm starting to
do better with
being around her kids and you have a
good relationship with your mom yeah i
have a good relationship with her it can
be better but
i have a good relationship with her as
far as
us and love and loyalty
but that was one of the main reasons why
i was out there even on the streets
before
because i was
you know a person i don't know nothing
or do know
but don't know a lot or don't get
attention
or stuff like that or don't get the love
that they need at the time
gonna seek somewhere else for other
stuff like that
why do you think why do you think you
run away in the first place
because the whole reason was
because my mom wasn't giving me no
attention and i'm
because she was busy working she was
busy working or
you know busy doing what she traveled
for work you know yeah
and even we moved out here she
started she had a boyfriend or whatever
so
it was just it was a lot going on living
in l.a you
you ran away at one point yeah i had
left
because did you run away or you just
didn't come home one night
i ran i left yeah i didn't come back and
then then somehow you got mixed up into
prostitution how did that happen
um i had
a friend and she was a hoe and
at the time i didn't know how to do what
or what to do what like i didn't even
know about
all this prostitution i didn't even know
about none of this
mind you i'm a kansas girl i'm 13 years
old yeah
i don't i don't know about numbers but
i got on the blade on fig
i didn't i just knew it was caught
figure i didn't know a lot
at all but i went
and i was so confused because you know
other people yelling at me and stuff i'm
confused like you know
had you had sex before you were 13 years
old yeah i already
lost my virginity that's that's when i
lost my virginity is when i started
messing up more
and started wanting to see more
life or just started leaving running
because of the
what's going on at home but
other than that it was no reason for me
to really leave or do
any of that stuff it's just the only
reason i was doing any prostitution or
doing anything like that here because
where else am i going to go you know
where who's going to take care of me who
will make sure i'm stable because i've
never had
a stable home like so when somebody
offers me stable
stability or um
you know or you know put a lot of stuff
in my head it's just like
i'ma take it because
[Music]
i never had nobody approach me like that
so when i started
i didn't know nothing but
my friend she was more telling me how to
do everything and from there i just
started and we were doing it together
but
i don't know where she at now you're
working with the pimp
yeah at the time um
at the time i was but i don't like i
said i don't know what happened to
nobody no more like i don't know
where nobody went from me leaving back
home i don't know where everybody went
from there but
and today are you still working no i
don't do
i don't i ain't been i'm pregnant now
you're pregnant now
yes six months six months
july 23rd i have my baby but i don't
i ain't been outside working on the
streets or nothing like that because i
just feel like
i'm i'm brave enough but like
you're a very brave girl it's just a lot
of
i got a lot going on and then i'm
praying that i want to put my baby in
nothing now maybe
if you know i was older
or something like that and time came
but even then i wouldn't know what
was going to happen by the time i'm
grown well what i find interesting about
your story is
you're only 14 you were 13 doing this
but now you're pregnant
do you know the father of your child no
so before i had left
um in the last video before i had left
before i had met up with my mom and
everything and we went back
out back home something i
ended up getting raped by a person that
i was with and
that person now is not alive so
to be honest i'm just the mother and
mother and father to my child i got my
family but as far as
a fatherly type thing you know i
honestly didn't know my biological
father
so i know
it might be like i don't want it to
be like a generational curse you know
something like that because i
i went through the same thing that my
daughter might go through or she might
not you know
i'm trying to make it to where she's not
going through yeah so
um other than that though but what i
find interesting about your story is so
now you're pregnant and you're 14
and you're forced by the legal system to
stay in los
angeles apart from your family who seems
like a good loving family
in wichita kansas right but you can't go
there
because and you you're a 14 year old who
doesn't really
i mean how are you going to support your
child how are you everybody be telling
me
go home you need to go home and stuff
like that
don't you think i tried like don't you
think i've
actually tried to go home like go do
what i got to do
like nah that's right
they're gonna see me right back out here
because it's a policy whatever i don't
know but
i know i'm gonna be back home soon i'm
gonna be able to live my life with my
baby my family
and we're not gonna have to deal with
none of this telling me it would be
better
yeah this is handling your case rather
than los angeles right
yeah the only reason i'm not
like i'm not gonna say but one thing i'm
not gonna do is sit here and let them
ruin my life and
like i'm not gonna let this system ruin
my life at all because
they have they're not it's not like
they're trying to keep me safe because
they're not
because if you can you know well here's
this is what i was about to say
is what i find interesting about your
story is you're 14 years old yeah
you're not 24 or 34 you're 14. yeah and
you're pregnant with a child and
in three months you're going to have a
baby yep
yeah you can't go home to your family
where maybe you can get some more
support yeah
and it's like it's messed up because
even when i went out there i was
pregnant
when i went back out there by myself
it's not like you're doing drugs you've
never done drugs i don't
know and maybe some bacteria they
brought you from kansas city where you
were you were with your family
they had you fly back to l.a yeah where
have you been staying while you've been
in l.a
with my friends or
mostly with friends when you're 14. i'm
surprised they just like
well her mom is there so her mom she's
not really
she don't you know she knows what's
going on she know me and it's not like
i'm lying or nothing but like
i just been with my best friend most
likely
we go places we have fun you know we
she makes sure i'm straight if anything
she makes sure i'm straight she's not
gonna leave me out
on the street you know because i don't
have
you know nobody out here my family's
that's what i'm saying so if i was ever
even doing any prostitution or anything
like that that's because
where what else am i supposed to do like
you know and i'm not going to let this
system put stuff in my head and
and fail me because
they want to have this policy and this
this and that when you're not even y'all
don't even care
i honestly don't yeah i don't your mom
seems you know a stable household for
you yeah
my mom has a whole house now i have my
own apartment out there right now
all um so you have an apartment back
there yeah so you wouldn't be staying
with your mom
i've always been i don't
i've always have to act older than my
age like i said
you know my mom too 14 year old she
tends to understand that now
so as far as me getting an apartment and
stuff
i'ma get that you know have my baby have
you know i'm be by myself because i like
being by myself right i don't like being
around everybody
like at all but you're an extraordinary
14 year old
i've never met another 14 year old quite
like you yeah i don't
i just i'll be having a lot going on
in my head people think i'm crazy i'm
not crazy though i'm crazy but you're
very courageous i'm just
and you're very bold you make very bold
moves right you're not timid
nobody gonna like
ever stop me from what i'm doing if i
want to say that like
unless it's something that's really bad
like but as far as
me like being myself you're not going
you can't like stop me from being myself
what are you what are your goals for
your life
when i have you finished high school no
how far do you go in school this since
this all this stuff corona been going on
i even been
back at school but that's i my
when i ran out here is around right
after school got out
which was because of corona yeah but how
many years
do you have left of high school
four yeah at least four
[Music]
yeah that's that's that's doable
yeah so
what are your thoughts now on your crazy
experience
of working figaro street as a 13 year
old
i just feel like to be honest it wasn't
really
me wanting to do it nobody forced me to
do it nobody making me do it
you weren't it was more are you
trafficked or forced into doing it true
yeah i was never forced none of that
like
nobody ever forced me to do anything
it's just i didn't have nowhere else to
be at go none of that like i said i'm
from way out there
so
when people i used to think of that as
you're taking care of me
you know so like of course i knew how to
do what i was doing i know the game i
know
you know but like i started having to
realize especially when i got pregnant
like okay i can't keep doing
this if i want to be by myself i got to
move
around how like somebody grown would
like you know i can't just you've grown
up very fast
yeah i can't just go outside
and be making money and doing all that
and then i already know people already
know
really who i am at that and
so i don't want you know nothing to
happen to my baby
or nothing happened to me because i want
to put
myself in danger you know
so it's a very dangerous lifestyle that
you were you were living yeah but
i got through it you know there's
nothing bad about it i'm not gonna say
it's nothing bad about it but it's just
did you enjoy it like was that right i
mean a lot of the girls get addicted to
that lifestyle and they they almost seem
like i started to get it
down not gonna lie it did start to get
addicting because
you got so much different people
and drama and so much different stuff
going on
and then you know you got
the men the you know you got all that
i want to fast money like you know but
it's just for the right people at the
right time
it's not necessarily for just anybody
it can be for anybody but it's not was
the hardest part for you
um after me getting raped was more the
hardest part for me because like i said
nobody was ever forcing me to do nothing
so i never had to worry about getting
away from anybody
but the hardest part was getting raped
and being held at gunpoint that's the
only
i think i mentioned that before but
gunpoint from a trick
yeah the rape the rape was from a pimp
yeah but the being robbed or being
healthy gun point was from a trick yeah
that was from a trick when i first
started
is it the excitement and the danger of
it that makes it
addicting for girls i feel like it's
just the fast money in
the building and you know
some people do get somewhere in life
doing that like you know
not everybody just turns into a
crackhead or turns into something
that they wasn't before like some people
really
shine from this stuff and
end up being real like stunning girl
she's one of the girls that probably was
prostituted and
what she was and look at her now she
popping period what have you learned
from doing that um
i learned other ways to make money it's
not that's not the only
not the only way to make money and it's
definitely not
it's dangerous yeah but i'm so brave i
can't say
it's dangerous to me like all i can say
is like you know it happened like you
know but
i mean i would recommend you know you
you certainly have courage and bravery
yeah god bless you never scared me i was
always i was
just protected i always had a shield
over myself
while i was out there i would just find
something better to apply your
courage and bravery toward yeah like i'm
gonna
pretty soon i'm gonna have a book y'all
gonna be able to read my
book yeah your life would be a great
story because
i've been through a lot even more than
you know
what y'all heard about me or what i've
told y'all it's way much more than that
like my life it's not a bad life it's
just the interest in life my life is
real interesting like
something new happens every day
so are you still working as a prostitute
okay so i've only worked
one time one time
i went to pomona and i was only out
there like at least
i say five minutes like walking
at least five minutes that was recently
i just got yeah this was like
at least last week and i was out there
with a friend
and vice jumped out on us
and we all just started running usually
i really don't run
i really just you know end up telling
him okay
let's get this over with cause y'all
gonna be chasing me down you've been
arrested before you know yeah
so um but this time i ran
because i seen everybody else running so
i was like oh i'm gonna go too
you know but i left i ran and um
ended up passing out uh
they tackled me while pregnant
everything they didn't know who i was
though yet so
i feel like that's why they did that
because i was still running like i kept
going like so they tackled me
and they tased me on my hand right here
and then the police officer that did it
got in trouble
because he didn't know my age you know i
was pregnant you can't do that
so after that happened
um i don't know like i said them
the citizens don't care like they don't
care so i left
you know because all i'm trying to do is
get home i'm not trying to
yeah i'm not trying to you know stay in
the placements and all that
but you end up working again for what
reason yeah
so one i was hungry needed clothes and
you're hungry
i was hungry i needed clothes and my
friend was
and she was influencing me a lot to just
she was like oh
she wanted me to go out there with her
because basically she
didn't want to go out there by herself
so
i went with her peer pressure yeah i
went with her no and it was stupid
because as soon as i got out there god
told me no are you religious i mean
i i believe in my ancestors
i believe in my spirit and i believe in
that anything that you
say or do or want in life or
whatever you want in life
you have to do it or
you have to i don't know i just feel
like
you have to do everything yourself for
yours you have to love yourself that's
what i feel like
if you want god helps those that help
themselves
yeah you gotta love you before anybody
else loves you for you
you know because it's not you gotta love
yourself first you're a very wise 14
year old
yeah i don't know as i was telling you
in the car it's like
most 14 year old most parents would not
want this kind of experience
this knowledge that you have for their
14 year old for their young
teenage daughter but the knowledge that
you have i think is
it's very unique and i think
i think that i'm getting it from my mom
you're smart you're clever you're strong
you're courageous you have a lot of
great qualities
yeah you just kind of got on the wrong
track and i'll never
go back to that life i wouldn't
okay let me not say i wouldn't go back
to that life ever again because i don't
know what will happen
in the future or where i'm at from now
but
i know right now i'm on a good track and
i'm trying to stay on
the same track i'm not trying to
just trying to get home that's it i got
a baby
to have now i want to make sure she's
she's safe so
what advice would you give to a girl
who's four or five years older than you
who's thinking about
getting into this life or somebody who's
your age
um for somebody that's my age
if you gonna do it
i feel like you should stay distance
when you do it don't do it
around everybody you know
or if you're gonna do it don't tell your
business like
make sure you keep everything you know
so you're at your attitudes it's it's
kind of okay unless somebody's taking
care of you
and you really need that help let them
know what they're dealing with because
not letting them know what they're
dealing with anything can happen you
know it's
already a life that's not that everybody
can't live
so make sure you tell the truth be
honest do you think it's an okay
lifestyle for for some girls
some girls that's you know that's up to
them you know like
however they got in the game is how they
got in the game yeah i mean i've
interviewed so many now that
there there are a handful that just like
it seems to be okay and they don't seem
to be depressed or they don't seem to be
in
trouble it's just depend on who you're
with
like and who you're around like can't be
around a bad energy or some
a bad person and then expect everything
to be good because it's not
y'all got to be on the same mindset tell
me what your opinion is of pimps
or your thought of pens because there's
many different types of pips first off
um like you said there's many different
types do you have a pimp pimp or do you
have a whole hustler
a gang member oh hustler right there's
so many pimps that are gay members
and so many people i call them all pimps
but but some are clearly just gang
members that are hustling girls and
other ones are
like the bishop or you know
the foods that are doing what they have
to do for their
like then i don't see nothing bad about
them either you know
everybody has a struggle in life and i
feel like okay
and i was just somebody that's two
people that are building together
and elevating together i don't feel like
there's nothing bad wrong with it it
just
depends on what situation you're in
because you could be in a bad situation
and yeah i'll be like you need to
move away from that girl but i think
that subculture of pimps and hoes is one
of the most misunderstood
subcultures we have elevating and
building
i'm not saying it's good but it's but
it's very misunderstood yeah
people think it's i don't think i don't
think it's evil and bad yeah it's not
people think nobody's but it can be at
the same time
it can be because a lot of that that's
why i said it depends on who you're
dealing with exactly
you know if you're real
hold that like like that go out there
and do your stuff and do what you got to
do
and you got somebody that's that's
helping you
get there and he want to see you
be great and see you elevate and see you
make it to the top and y'all both make
it to the top then you're all good you
know it's something
i've met some some i've interviewed some
i have not interviewed who i know
very well now who are they're doing the
right thing by their
girls i mean yes their girls are doing
what you were doing at one point but
but they're they're not exploiting
anybody they're they're they're
elevating as you said
you know you have to understand this is
a subcla this is a culture
that these girls come from very few
opportunities they didn't go to college
they don't
high school education wasn't going to
really benefit yeah they dropped out or
yeah and it's like they come from the
streets and he's doing the best thing by
them and
i think it's misunderstood because it's
so kind of hidden and
a lot of people don't understand this
the streets anyway so
yeah that's why it's misunderstood
[Music]
i would say not all pimps and hoes are
as bad as
people like to yeah stereotyping it's
really not
so your mom's excited to see you come
home yeah she's really excited once i
get down there we're gonna
start doing you know more for the baby
are you excited to see your sister yeah
i'm excited to see her
your sister's different than you i take
it right she's way different than me
your mom's probably having two of you
would be very tired yeah we're too
different me my little sister are two
different people
honestly and it wasn't like you guys
were raised that differently right
probably raised exactly the same there's
something in your personality that
led you down this path and she's more of
the
no don't do that you know like no
yeah she's more than like why are you
doing that or like she
she she don't like going nowhere she
likes things she aquarius
it's young
so you're very bold yeah i'm a scorpio
where do you think you got that from my
dad your dad
um i wouldn't say my dad i'd give my
boldness from actually
i was saying myself and
myself i feel like i'm just bold period
like my mom not really [ __ ]
she bold but she's not both like i am
like
on board like you are dude
you think for yourself i mean you don't
really listen to other people you just
do what
harmony wants to do when it comes to
certain stuff
but as far as my mind and how i think i
i just feel like that's how i'm going to
be like
that's how i'm thinking you know unless
something need to change i'll make sure
it changes no matter what i think
because i have a struggle with that too
but
i think you're amazing you're one of the
most fascinating people i've interviewed
yeah for all kinds of different reasons
a lot of people say
i'm like sunshine and darkness and i'm
like
a light that just came out of nowhere
and just
brightened everybody up but i don't be
knowing how cause it'd be like me
i'll just be chilling i think you're
very very special
i think you're going to do some great
things in your life and
you'll even take what you just did on
your 13th year of life and probably turn
it into something great one day
i can totally see that yeah and i see
you changing the direction of your life
very clearly very easily and
i hope you continue with that and i hope
your baby is great and
i hope you're happy as can be you come
in three months from now
i'm excited for you yep i'm ready too
all right harmony well thank you for
coming back you're i'm flying you back
to kansas city after this right
yeah you are i know you won't find me
back i hope you don't have to come back
to l.a
me either because i'm tired of this but
if i just my child gonna be out there
safe that's all i care about
but i'm going out there to hide this
baby they're not gonna stop me
i'm sorry now if i to come back and do
what i got to do
then okay excellent
all right harmony thank you so much
you're welcome
during that first video you just told me
that you were
yeah you were kind of lying partially
because you had a pimp
yeah at the time and i didn't want
nothing to happen like
to me or you know need to get
you know anything happen to me because
at the time when he supposed to be doing
one thing i was doing a whole
different thing and when he found out it
was
later on in life so you know because
i've done so many of these interviews
now with
different girls they all tell me they
don't have pimps but i know they do
very often they do i feel like why would
why would a girl have a cow
i feel like because i mean i don't
really understand why
you give him all the money and you don't
get none of it back like if you're
really like
if you really know like a lot about
what you come from and who you are and
what men come from
you would know like if you're working
for
a man or a paper or anything like that
any man came from a woman
so if like
men are supposed to be out there working
for the women that's the way it works in
most of the culture
most of the world so like i would
confuse sometimes like you know why i
gave a pimp all your money like
it don't make sense to me but a lot of
women
some girls just do it because you know
they
it's more than just whatever they got
going on
more than just dipping it on but i feel
like
if they if a girl is giving guy her
money there she's
she's she really knows what she's doing
with it he if a girl is giving a guy
her money he knows what he's doing with
it i hope so
i hope he's she's she's not going to get
it when you go
separate ways that's why it's called
stay down
you know for your crown stay down for
what does that mean i mean stay down and
stay with your
your folks and you know don't go nowhere
cause it's all gone oh don't leave don't
leave and go to another pimp
yeah because you'll lose all my money no
because
you you have to start all over again
and rebuild your little nest egg that he
controls
yep and you're probably not going to get
in the end
it's like just moving and moving it's
moving you're not going to get nowhere
yeah if it's the worst investment that's
how you get yourself out get on drugs
and stuff like that
yeah see once a girl knows that she's
probably not going to get all that money
she's
sold her ass for for all that time
that would make you that would make me
want to smoke crack too i think every ho
knows though that they're not going to
get numb
like you don't get it's
yeah it's i mean i don't know why do you
think women do it
easy i feel like it's either because
they want to and they really love that
life or they just
struggling in life or they're just going
through stuff
they never had the guidance by that
person or
you know or they never had guidance or
never
had the right attention or
anything like that when they were little